late on a Saturday afternoon a shopping  mall in Thailand came under attack a  gunman opened fire at a time when it  would have been at its busiest here he  can be seen firing multiple rounds  towards people and passing cars people  found whatever cover they could after he  entered the mall panicked shoppers ran  out their day coming to a terrifying end  this was the heavily armed gunman  seeming to walk casually through the  mall he had earlier been named by police  as chakra pants tomorr a 32 year old  soldier in the Thai army he began his  rampage hours earlier by killing a  commanding officer on a military base  outside the city as he continued his  murderous spree he posted updates on  social media including this one where he  complained that his finger was sore from  pulling the trigger so many times gun  violence is common in this country but  not on the scale this will be remembered  as one of Thailand's darkest days Wayne  hey al Jazeera Bangkok